[Musique]
foire des enfants bon choix
ou patrons encore pu encore une étoile
filante
elle est magnifique et cette fois je
fais un voeu patron et peut-on savoir
lequel ah ça c'est mon secret
mister
monde le seul
ne traînez pas trop monsieur le
mystérieux
popopopop aux caprices tu vas avoir un
pull-over
extraordinaire quel journal cape des
mauvaises nouvelles nicolas mais c'est
pas lui c'est vrai mais je sens bon soir
la compagnie au tout le monde travaille
chez nous tu arrives à te oui tu vas
pouvoir me dire bonjour marne
tu vas tenir debout
au
preneur merci tu me tricoter un pull
overs
radis pour toi là nous allons essayer
sur la maquette crif allons caprices
[Musique]
le bouchon plus
tu vas avoir un bon tri couteau vers
du troll
c'est bien attention non pas de fessiers
ça ne se fait plus j'ai une idée sans
telle une chanson à cette caprice salah
calme aura à oui c'est une bonne idée
écoute bien qu a prise
moi c'est la fin de la journée
c'est le moment de se couchait nous
faisons comme nos amis ils sont tous en
vie
nous y allons jos est
sur son nuage
j'en suis certain le marchand de sable
vient
il nous dira
fermez vos yeux et dom et tous les deux
nous sommes bien dans notre lit nos
mouflets pas bonne nuit sa grosse voix
m'a fait plaisir quand je vais me dormir
non je vais m'endormir
safra nous fait plaisir
[Musique]
bonne nuit les enfants
mais je ne vais pas ici qu'est ce qu'il
a fait
il ne faut pas réveiller un enfant qui
dort
[Musique]
on dormait vous vu la nuit qu'après
une nuit la mer la jette à la lueur
fait de bord
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous aussi des enfants allez vite vous
coucher comme pas prenait les nicolas et
comme caprice elle a été très sage elle
s'est endormie la première n'oubliez pas
de faire votre toilette lavez vous les
dents est fait pour
[Musique]
alors